so right here in front of me i have
every single ipad from apple's current
ipad lineup
we've got the budget 10.2 inch ipad for
329 we've got the ipad mini 5
for 400. we've got the ipad air 4 the
brand new one
for 600 and the 20 20 11
ipad pro for 800 so in this video i'm
gonna show you guys all of the
differences between them
to help you decide which ipad you should
be buying
for your specific use case and since the
last version of this video
my purchasing recommendations have
changed drastically
thanks to the updated budget ipad and
the new ipad air 4
but before i talk about the one ipad
that you definitely
should not buy right now let's get into
comparing all of the physical
differences
the ipad air has now moved on to the
modern design of the ipad pro
which includes flat sides like the new
iphone 12
an edge to edge display with rounded
corners compared to square corners on
the other ipads
and even bezels all around thanks to
removing the home button from the front
making them look so much more modern
compared to the ipad in the ipad mini
now while the ipad pro gets face id
authentication
the ipad air 4 gets a new touch id in
the power button
and to be completely honest it doesn't
work nearly as well as face id
and i'd argue that the placement of the
sensor is a bit awkward
but it's totally worth the new display
moving over to the back side
the air and the pro get a completely
flat back and they both get larger
camera bumps that stick out
but they look more premium the pro does
take it a step further
by having a square camera bump like the
new iphones
which i think looks great the ipad mini
is the only one
out of the lineup that doesn't have
apple smart connector
which is used for connecting keyboard
accessories and while the air and the
pro have a larger connector on the back
of the ipad
the budget 10.2 inch ipad has it on the
side
now what makes the ipad air a great
value is that it supports
apple's magic keyboard which i think is
the best keyboard case ever made
because of the unique hinge design and
the pass-through charging port
but it's a little bit pricey at 300
thankfully logitech has excellent folio
and combo touch keyboards for each ipad
other than the mini because it's just
too small in terms of the speakers
both the air and the pro get speaker
grilles on both the top and the bottom
but only the pro has quad speakers
with the air simply having one speaker
on each side
which is still better than the budget
ipad and the mini
which only gets speaker grilles on the
bottom leading to much worse audio
quality
as you'll see in just a minute in our
speaker comparison the air and the pro
both get usb-c
ports which is the best case scenario
compared to lightning on the other two
since it gives you better accessory
support and it's also important to note
that the pro's usb-c
port is twice as fast as the one on the
air
as far as the chargers that come in the
box the ipad mini is the only one that
doesn't get apple's new 20 watt charger
instead it gets an old and outdated 12
watt usb a
charger which won't support fast
charging on apple's new
iphone 12 lineup however the mini does
get a headphone jack
just like the budget ipad and
unfortunately the air and the pro
no longer get that now getting into
display quality they all have
at least 264 pixels per inch with the
mini having a bit more
because of the small 7.9 inch display
the budget ipad gets a 10.2 inch display
which is a decent size but i like the 11
inch display size of the pro
the best now while the air has the same
exact body size as the pro
the display is slightly smaller at 10.9
inches due to having thicker bezels
for some reason in terms of display
brightness the pro
can actually reach 600 nits of
brightness compared to only 500
with all of the other ipads even the new
air
but out of all of these the budget ipad
gets the absolute
worst display quality since the display
is
non-laminated this means that there's
actually a gap
in between the glass and the display
which can be noticeable by looking
at it from the side and it also makes it
feel a bit hollow
instead of solid like the rest of the
ipads the budget ipad is also much more
reflective compared to the others
which have anti-reflective coatings and
taking it even
further the budget ipad lacks true tone
technology
which automatically adjusts the white
balance of the display to match your
surroundings
and it doesn't support p3 wide colors
either
so the color accuracy isn't as good as
on the other ipads
now while the display on the ipad air
seems like it matches the ipad pro
the air is actually missing 120 hertz
pro motion technology
which allows the display to
automatically adjust between 24
hertz and 120 hertz based on what you're
doing
like playing a game that supports 120
frames per second
and as you can see from the slow-motion
clip between the air and the pro
the display on the pro is super smooth
for scrolling and everything else
promotion also greatly reduces the
latency of the apple pencil
down to 9 milliseconds on the ipad pro
as you can see in this slow motion clip
giving it the best apple pencil
experience out of all of these ipads
now besides that the ipad air now
finally supports the second generation
apple pencil
which uses wireless charging on the side
to both
charge and pair just like we already had
on the pro
another great benefit of this pencil is
the new design and the added
double tap gesture support for swapping
tools and other things like that
but both the ipad mini and the budget
ipad
are still limited to the original apple
pencil which uses
lightning to charge and the budget ipad
also has the worst apple pencil
experience
because of the non-laminated display
which gives it a noticeable gap between
the pencil tip
and the actual display underneath the
glass
and with that let's finally get into our
speaker comparison
so where are we
now before we get into the performance
let's quickly compare
the cameras both the air and the pro get
a 12 megapixel wide camera on the back
compared to 8 megapixels on the other
two giving them better
detail and photos and the ability to
record 4k video at 60 frames per second
compared to just 1080p 30 on the others
the pro
is also the only one that gets the extra
10 megapixel ultrawide camera
which gives you a unique perspective
that you can't get on the other ipads
and it's also the only one that has a
flash which can be useful for document
scanning
the pro is also the only one that gets
the lidar scanner
which greatly improves depth tracking
for things like augmented reality apps
so in this comparison to an ipad without
lidar
you can tell that it's able to detect
objects and distance
much more accurately now as far as the
front-facing cameras
the budget ipad still gets a very bad
quality
1.2 megapixel selfie camera compared to
seven on the rest
so selfies are going to look quite worse
especially compared to the pro
which uses face id sensors to enable
portrait mode
the ipad pro also gets five microphones
compared to
two mics on the rest of these ipads so
it should sound
much better as well as you can hear in
this comparison
this is the webcam and microphone
quality on the 2020
10.2 inch budget ipad this is the webcam
and microphone quality on the ipad
mini 5. this is the webcam and
microphone quality on the 2020 ipad air
4.
and this is the webcam and microphone
quality on the
2020 ipad pro now let's finally get into
performance
both the budget ipad and the ipad mini
only get 3 gigabytes of ram
compared to 4 on the air and 6 on the
pro
as far as the chips the budget ipad and
the mini have the a12 bionic chip from
the iphone 10s
while the air has the brand new a14 chip
from the iphone 12 lineup
and the ipad pro has the super powerful
a12
z chip comparing single core performance
in geekbench 5
the ipad air destroys all the other
ipads including the pro
because it's using the latest and
greatest tech from apple
but in terms of the multi-core
performance the pro still outperforms
the air
by about 400 points and both of them are
much more powerful than
the other two ipads and for graphics
performance
the air surprisingly beats out the pro
by
just a little bit but they're both over
two
times more powerful than the mini and
the budget ipad
in terms of gaming performance those
lower end ipads still do an
excellent job for things like call of
duty mobile running at a smooth
60 frames per second now if you want to
play higher end games
like maybe gentian impact or something
like that
the extra performance of the air and the
pro will give you
extra peace of mind but out of all of
them the ipad pro is the
absolute best choice for gaming because
it supports
120 frames per second gaming thanks to
having pro motion technology
now as far as a couple of other spec
differences the budget ipad gets
bluetooth 4.2
compared to 5.0 on the others and this
year
the new ipad air 4 gets wi-fi 6 just
like the ipad pro
and as for the battery life apple rates
them at the same
10 hours like they always do now with
all of that said
let's finally get into my purchasing
recommendations
starting with who should buy the budget
10.2 inch ipad and why
the value of this ipad jumped through
the roof this year
because it went from the old a10 chip to
the a12
which means it feels much more snappy
for everything from navigation
using apps and playing games since we
got a solid 60fps in call of duty mobile
and because of the 329 price it's an
absolutely great choice for kids and
teens
since they probably won't mind the worst
quality
non-laminated display but that's also a
plus
because it's much cheaper and easier to
replace
not only that but the budget ipad is
also great for adults
for working from home since you can get
a full laptop replacement package
for much cheaper than any other ipad by
buying the logitech combo touch keyboard
case
which comes with a track pad so it
basically turns it into a budget macbook
and by the way the budget 10.2 inch ipad
is now on sale on amazon
for only 300 by using the link down
below in the video description
but i'd personally recommend going for
the 128 gig model
if you're gonna be playing games or
downloading large apps
now moving on to the ipad mini even
though it's only 70 dollars more
expensive than the budget ipad
it's actually by far the worst value
out of all of the ipads this year it's
not any faster than the budget ipad
since they both have the same a12 chip
and while you do get a better laminated
display
it's many times worse than the ipad air
4 for 200
more for a number of different reasons
like having the old
design and supporting the old apple
pencil
and on top of that the mini is the only
ipad that doesn't come with this smart
connector
so it doesn't support high quality
keyboard cases
but by far the biggest reason you should
not buy the mini
is because there have been leaks and
rumors of a completely redesigned
8.5 inch ipad mini 6 coming in the first
half of next year
so if you buy this mini right now you're
probably going to be disappointed when
you see the new redesign
however if you don't really care about
that the mini is still a great choice
for kids and teens since it's smaller so
it's easier to hold in your hands
while playing games now moving on to the
brand new ipad air 4
this one is in a pretty weird spot at
600 dollars
it sits right in between the mini and
the ipad pro
for 800. yes it gets the brand new
design with support for the new pencil
it gets the usb-c port which is awesome
and it gets support for the magic
keyboard case which is the best case
ever made
so from the looks of it it looks like an
ipad pro
killer but once you dig a little bit
deeper you'll start to see how many
downsides it has compared to the pro
which i'll mention in just a minute but
the biggest downside of the air
is that while it gets the a14 chip with
killer graphics performance
you can't use it to the full potential
because the air
does not have 120 hertz promotion tech
because of that the gaming performance
is similar to the cheaper ipads which is
a bit disappointing
and on top of that it only comes with 64
gigs of storage
compared to 128 on the pro so if you
want more
you have to go straight to 256 gigs
which brings the price up to 750 dollars
basically right in ipad pro territory so
honestly
there are only a few reasons why anybody
should buy the new air
the first reason is if you want that new
redesign instead of buying the cheaper
ipads
which will start to look outdated very
soon the second reason is if you want
that a14
chip that's gonna have software support
for many more years
the third reason is if you have a hard
limit
of six hundred dollars to spend on an
ipad
so you can't justify going for the pro
and finally
the air is a great choice if you really
just want
the magic keyboard case since you can
get it for a total of nine hundred
dollars with the air
instead of eleven hundred dollars with
the pro and now
finally let's get into who should be
buying the ipad
pro if you want the best and most
premium tablet
ever made this is the one to get and if
you take gaming
seriously then this ipad is the one to
buy because it's the only one
with a 120hz display and it's got
basically the same graphics power as the
air
but on top of that it has the highest
multi-core cpu performance
and it comes with six gigs of ram
compared to four on the air
and three on the cheaper ipads it's also
got by far
the best speakers and microphone quality
the bezels are thinner than on the air
and the usb-c
port is twice as fast the display also
gets brighter
than any other ipad it's basically the
best of the best
and it comes with 128 gigs of storage
which is actually a solid amount that
most people will be completely fine with
even gamers and on top of that the 11
inch model is now on sale
for 750 bucks on amazon which is a
killer deal for what you get
and don't forget that there's also the
larger 12.9 inch model
if you really want to replace your
laptop however
the final thing to consider is that we
should be seeing a new ipad pro
with the a14x chip within half a year
and i believe that the performance on
that ipad pro
is gonna be mind-blowing so keep that in
mind as well
so there you guys go there are all of
the differences between these ipads
and if this video helps you make a
decision feel free to use the links down
below to help this channel out
and if it didn't help you go ahead and
comment down below and i'm gonna reach
out and comment
and help you decide which one to buy and
definitely check out our full ipad
air versus ipad pro comparison video
right over
there thank you guys for watching and
we'll see you in the next one